The graph shows on the
horizontal axis the percentage
of questions answered,
and on the vertical axis,
the percentage of answers
that were correct.
When Watson started, the graph
that shows its performance
is shown here.
In 2007, we observed that the
performance of Watson improved,
and it is shown there.
And then successively
from 2008 May to 2010,
we see the successive
improvement of Watson
in this graph that shows a
trade-off between questions
answered and precision.
This is the area of
the best human players.
Observe that they answer
a high number of questions
and they answer a very high
number of questions correctly.
So it was at that time--
2010-- that the people that
controlled the decision
decided that Watson
is ready to enter
the competition.
So the games were scheduled
for February 2011.
Two games were
played, and the winner
would be the contestant with the
highest winnings over the two
games.
Once we got into the game, it
was nerve-wracking, frankly.
Brad, if you're ready,
make your first choice.
Let's take "Alternate
Meanings" for $200, Alex.
"4-letter word for a
vantage point or a belief."
Brad.
What is a view?
Yes.
After the first clue of
the game, which Brad won,
I had just this horrible
feeling at that moment
that he was as good as
everyone said he was,
and he was just going to
run the whole board on us.
"Alternate Meanings," $400.
"4-letter word for the iron
fitting on the hoof of a horse
or a card-dealing
box in a casino."
Watson.
What is shoe?
You are right.
We actually took the lead.
We were ahead of them.
But then we started getting
some questions wrong.
Watson.
What is leg?
No, I'm sorry, I
can't accept that.
What is 1920s?
No.
What is chic?
No, sorry.
Brad?
What is class?
Class, you got it.
Watson.
What is Sauron?
Sauron is right,
and that puts you
into a tie for the
lead with Brad.
A lot of people
were feeling good
because Watson held his own
and was doing pretty well.
But I wanted to be winning.
Too close for comfort.
Ken, you're in third place.
That means you go first
in "Double Jeopardy."
The "Double Jeopardy" round
of the first game I thought
was phenomenal.
00:03:03.830
which describes the relationship
between different words.
For example, the lexicon
could tell Watson
that water is a clear liquid,
but not all clear liquids
are water.
Another tool Watson
had was a part
of speech tagger and parser.
This would identify
functions of words in text.
For example, it would
know that the word "race"
can be used as a verb or a noun.
"The students had to
race to catch the bus"
uses race as a verb, while
"Please indicate your race"
uses race as a noun.
Then, using these data
sources and tools,
Watson would answer
a question by going
through four major steps.
The first step is
question analysis,
where Watson tries
to figure out what
the question is looking for.
The second step is
hypothesis generation,
where Watson searches
the information
sources for possible answers.
After this, Watson
moves on to step
three, when the different
hypotheses are scored.
This means that a
confidence level
has to be computed
for each answer.
The final step is
ranking the hypotheses
to look for a
highly-supported answer.
In the next two videos, we'll go
through how each of these steps
work.ou a sense
of how incredible the human
brain is-- how quickly it
could understand the category,
what's being asked.
Boom!
And get the answer.
Who is Sean Penn?
Right.
Ken was doing very well.
And the risk was if Ken gets
a "Daily Double," that's big.
Gets it right, he's
going to be well ahead.
And then with that kind of lead
going into "Final Jeaoprady"--
if he bets enough, he could
end up winning the match.
"A camel is a horse
designed by this."
Ken.
What's a committee?
Good.
"Familiar Sayings" for $2,000.
We've gotta find that
last "Daily Double."
I was nail-biting.
It was just intense.
Because these guys were good.
Ken.
Who is the brain?
Brain, yes.
There was a crucial
moment in the game.
There was still a "Daily
Double" on the board
and it was starting to
become pretty clear that it
was in the "Legal E's" category.
Let's go to "Legal
E's" for $1,200.
"This person is
appointed by a testator
to carry out the directions
and requests in his will."
Watson.
What is executor?
Right.
Same category, $1,600.
Answer-- "Daily Double."
That was the moment
when I knew it's over.
Let us look at the
results of the game.
Looking at these numbers,
it is fair to say
that Watson's victory over
the two best human players
has been a decisive one.
In the first day,
Watson's winnings
were more than double the sum
of the winnings of both players.
And in the second day, it
was more than their sum.
Overall, the winnings for
Watson were almost double
the sum of the winnings
of both players--
a rather decisive victory.
So what's next for Watson?
So Watson is ideally suited
to answer questions which
cover a wide range
of material and often
have to deal with inconsistent
or incomplete information.
This makes it particularly
appropriate for applications
like medicine.
Note that the amount of
medical information available
is doubling every five
years, and a lot of the data
is unstructured.
As a result, Watson has been
utilized for cancer diagnosis
and selecting the best
course of treatment.
And Watson has
been in discussions
with MD Anderson and Memorial
Sloan-Kettering Cancer Centers
to apply the Watson technology
for cancer diagnosis
and selecting the best
course of treatment.
So what is the analytics
edge of Watson?
First, we have observed that
the major technology of Watson
is to combine many
algorithms that
increase the accuracy
and the confidence
of the overall outcome.
Any one of these algorithms
would not have worked,
but their combination gives
Watson a considerable edge.
The second important observation
that gives Watson an edge
is that it approaches the
problem in a very different way
than how a human
approaches a problem.
A key aspect of the technology
is hypothesis generation,
and then using different
and distinct algorithms
to explore this hypothesis
and combining them,
it leads to answers
that provide an edge.
Finally, and quite
importantly, Watson
has a considerable
ability to deal
with massive amounts of data,
often in unstructured form.
And the vast majority of the
data-- 90% of it-- is, in fact,
unstructured.
So the combination
of these ideas
give Watson a significant edge.
It is no accident that IBM has
invested so far more than $24
billion to invest in
Watson technologies,
and it has created
a company within IBM
called Watson Solutions,
whose key objective is
to apply the Watson
technology and the edge
that it creates to a variety
of verticals, one of which
is medicine.